[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett joining us a day at the round
table of dim lighting is youtuber lip
syncher aka that dude dressed up like
Miley Cyrus on chatroulette Steve
cardinal for those of you not familiar
with chat roulette it's a site that
pairs random people from around the
world together for webcam based
conversations and Steve has used this
site to help create some of the most
popular videos on the Internet including
one he did for Miley's wrecking ball if
you hadn't seen this he basically is on
chatroulette he lip syncs the song and
then gets that he films the strangers
reaction and he's in he's dressed in a
Miley Cyrus get up or not dressed at all
dressed in completely naked on a
wrecking ball on him medicine ball it's
suspended on a rope or something yeah
this thing not a medicine ball that
nexor so you know the exercise ball yeah
I knew what you meant I this thing blew
up on the internet in 2013 it continues
to wreak abuse currently at over 130
million views that's a lot of millions
Wow and we would play a clip for you but
it would just be Miley Cyrus's wrecking
ball and you know you probably heard
that before Steve also makes videos for
a series he calls songs in real life
where he lip syncs moments of various
songs and then places them into everyday
situations Steve would you stop sleeping
in my class all the time
I'd be sad too if I came to school
wearing my granddad's clothes we've
covered a lot of topics with Steve
including why a lost millions of views
on some of his chatroulette videos The
awkward source for his bikinis and the
reasons why behind there's so much time
sometimes over a year between his
blockbuster releases this guy is a
talented performer he has really helped
define a genre a web video and we were
glad to get to sit down and get to know
him a little bit better building a
website can be tough and even if you do
know your way around coding creating
something that looks good and works well
is a time consuming affair whether it's
for a business site a portfolio a
restaurant or whatever else in this day
and age if you have a pulse you need a
website a bolt and Squarespace makes it
easy to build beautiful websites without
breaking a sweat
Squarespace provides simple powerful and
beautiful website templates for you to
work with and those templates are part
of something called Squarespace is
responsive design which means your
website automatically scales to look
great on any device phone tablet
computer Palm Pilot I don't really know
if it works on a Palm Pilot but I really
hope that it does and it knows you are
you still here you seem oh it probably
doesn't and it doesn't matter it works
everywhere that you needed to work and
every website you build also comes with
a free online store and you definitely
need that you need to turn that store on
and make some money people sell
something caching and if you just need
something more minimalistic but still
powerful their cover page feature also
lets you allows you to set up a
beautiful one-page online presence in
minutes start a trial with no credit
card required and start building your
website today when you decide to sign up
for Squarespace make sure to use the
offer code rhett and Link rhett a nd
link to get 10% off your first purchase
and to show your support for air
biscuits thanks to Squarespace for their
support for your biscuits again
squarespace.com offer code rhett and
Link now onto the biscuit
what's your favorite condiment um like
pepper
so that's soy sauce that's not a
condiment really pepper and salt are
condiments
I thought connivance were usually sauces
I like my scissor c-listers my kind of
thing I mean when I mean hotdogs of
course you bet you do ketchup on a hot
dog I'm not really a big fan of ketchup
yeah I like it but I definitely I do I
like you but I smell a ketchup like
throws me off he's got a Vinit high
vinegar type smell yeah but mustard is
even higher of a smell but mustard just
I like you I like the something about
ketchup just really throws me I can't
really explain it
it's like blood it's like congealed
blood yep is that your reason because
don't let him put words you know if you
don't think Hector's like blood don't be
like yeah because that seems like a
stupid race more of like yes more the
smell okay good smell just really gets
me that's better oh yeah on january 31st
not too long ago you tweeted i think
youtube needs a new track chatroulette
video this year yep and they're gonna
get it again is a commitment is it
commitment have you made it it's a work
its work in progress they take a long
time to make and I've been gradually
kind of like working on it taking my
time with it but okay yeah it's gonna be
I'm not gonna say what song it is it's
kind of a surprise but it's gonna be a
good Charlotte video it's it's good it's
gonna be big
it's I mean it could rival the other
ones I hope I don't really want to like
you know talk Holly over then it kind of
flops but I'm feeling really good up
good about it so far I think it's gonna
be great well I don't want to skip to
the process I certainly have some
questions about the process especially
when you say how long it takes but I
don't want to get into that yet but we
probably should just go ahead and talk
about the Miley Cyrus wrecking ball chat
traveller that video because I mean
we're gonna have trouble saying
chatroulette chatte rules of us are
gonna have trouble with that like Russia
or like chatroulette
yeah I mean you can say that I'll be
seeing it wrong generally I know what it
is yeah Cheerilee yeah but I'm gonna say
cheboub wet yeah we thought that works
we both swallowed it alright
chatroulette video I mean when I see
your face I hear wreck
ball you know I mean how's that make you
feel what's the yeah I mean I don't mind
it's my it's my biggest video to date so
I mean yeah every time someone like sees
me in the streets or like a wrecking
ball guy and I usually had this face
where like when the video goes viral I
have videos go viral in the past and
people always recognize me for like I
used to be the bikini guy and then a
wrecking ball went viral and then I
wasn't that I was wrecking ball and then
I have a serious call song as real life
that was a song for a life guy but as of
now it's just like always a wrecking
ball guy I don't mind it it's it's
pretty cool so is the goal it seems like
maybe the goal is to continually come up
with something that then you become the
guy from the yeah that's how you measure
she says yes the next time I'm gonna be
the guy from whatever I do next
yeah you almost said it but you didn't I
kept yourself you know we read your mind
and now it we have the power to say it
or not you know I will I will say that
before this podcast link and I for the
first time ever went on chatroulette it
will speak for yourself and well you
were there as far as I remember cuz it
was just like an hour ago I had been on
it before oh oh really I'm gonna be
honest I went on it once before I think
it's when I saw your video the first
time when it was blowing up I was
wondering what it was and I quickly
found out that it didn't wasn't the
place for me I mean I I knew the I
understood what it was and kind of had
some idea but kind of going into that
environment just for like 15 minutes
just to be like we need to have
experience that's a little bit right
it's it's a uh well you do people yeah
why don't you just describe it give us
the yeah okay Cheryl that pretty much is
a website where you turn on your webcam
and you see other people with with
webcams and you have the choice either
next that person or talk to that person
so you can skip them yeah you can skip
them and usually when you're if you're a
guy on chatroulette you're gonna get
skipped a lot until you know if you're a
female you're gonna have you know people
don't want to talk to you that's what
that yeah of course so yeah just it's a
site with a big range of people and yeah
it's and and there's a
there's a webcam window in the upper
left hand corner that is the person that
you are looking at and then underneath
that you see yourself what what you see
what they're seeing of you and then
there's a whole big open space to the
right which is the chat window so the
video window is actually pretty small
hmm and there's a lot of room for chat I
feel like there should be more room for
the video right yeah I can see that the
whole screen just like the chat but and
then I want you to describe what like
typical seven minutes on chatroulette is
like to see if our experience earlier
today was correct well are you guys
talking have you seen like the naked
guys on there that you're talking about
I see there seemed like there were a lot
of guys who if the camera had it tilted
they would have been naked yeah but
cherrylle that has gotten a pretty
strict where like they have like certain
like you know there's rules now where if
you're like have your shirt off they're
gonna like ban you we got you're gonna
be suspended so it's a lot more
difficult to film videos on there now
but really yeah like omegle it's kind of
amigos like the side of uh I would share
a lot that I think the meal came after
chatroulette
so um Eagles the same kind of thing but
they have like no like you can go out on
their naked I think and they wouldn't be
as strict as chatroulette but omegle
yeah but cherry let when I'm on
chatroulette if they don't next if I'm
in like full cast and people usually
stick around but when I'm just go on
they're like talk to people say hi just
dressed like this I usually get next to
all the time
do you think that's because they
recognize you know I don't want to be in
a video I don't think there's been a few
like people will recognize me and talk
to me but I think most of time is just
guys on the quest to find love of their
life or you know and they see a beard
and they're out yep that's exactly it
but yeah because when we started
scrolling through it was just a bunch of
guys who were kind of zombified just
kind of a lot of Eastern Europeans
staring staring blankly into their
webcam yeah I guess into the picture
that we were sending of us which was
just us staring blankly back at them and
then they would just be gone because
they would next yeah and then we started
next in people and then there was a girl
so we stopped because whoa naturally
there actually are girls on here there's
like one out of 30 and she knew us oh no
and then it was like ha who should feel
guilty for being on here she was fully
clothed by the way but um
there was a wave of self-awareness of
what does she think of me being on
chatroulette did you tell her I was like
no she was like I could tell that it was
both of us and yeah yeah I could tell
they had the she recognizing hoodies on
they just kind of worked out that way
and we both were good mythical morning
hoodie because they were in our office
so it was like rhett and Link in uniform
on chatroulette but is it people just
wanting to have video sex
I think people actually people would go
on there to talk to meet new people but
well he's saying no if they've changed
the rules you can't do that now he is a
lot more strict now but back when I
years ago needs to do it it's all like I
feel like every other guy was was naked
and I was always eating nexted but very
rarely running these people out I just
want to talk and make new friends
well and and that's the interesting
thing about it is you know I heard it
was all about you know penises like
you'll see a lot of penis yeah on there
but then I watch your video and it has
this quite I mean you're buck naked by
the end of the thing or at least you
seem that way that's another question I
had a tube sock on you didn't go right
into it had a tube sock okay that was
one of our questions we can mark that
one out the list not a crew sock or a
ankle sock angle sake no heavy too risky
the tube sock I have my roommates around
me so I couldn't have an ankle sock on
yeah they were they were holding you up
on the vacuum box yeah they're on the
exercise ball yeah
but there's an interesting quality I
don't know exactly how to describe it
but it it's like a fun everyone's having
fun people are connecting and this isn't
dirty this is actually a celebration of
humanity look at these people smiling
and reacting and it took something dirty
or at least something that had a stigma
of being dirty and your video or videos
kind of turned it into something that
was like wow this is people are coming
together this is like freaking Montel
Williams the mixer make a penis yeah
mixture of happier reactions and was
that a discovery on your part or well
going into it I wanted your touching I
wanted to go for more of the like
happier reactions occasionally I'll get
like to discuss your reactions but I
want to have a video just full of like
joy you know because people see people
smiling
they smile that they love it they share
it that's what I was going for but I had
to go through a lot of like the you know
the the naked guys and like I have a lot
of that footage by the way that's just
it's Aleta now I used to have a lot of
footage over like this stuff I had like
to finally go to reactions I can imagine
yeah I'd rather not imagine but and and
you you got the attention of Miley I
mean kind of give us the touch points on
how big this thing got which really
culminates in you meeting her right oh
yeah well opening day I was expecting
maybe like a million because Sheryl at
my trial of videos have a pretty like
loyal following pretty big following and
I was especially maybe like 1 or 2
million views opening day but opening
day got like 10 million views within the
first week it was like 60 million views
well yeah it was just taken off and now
it's at like hundred and thirty million
views hundred thirty one
it's insane yeah that's and when you
released it it wasn't long after that
that her song which had which wasn't
number one anymore because lords Royals
was number one for like eight nine weeks
in a row
and then it was pretty much everyone
speculated and I think they were right
that when your video came out she
immediately went back to number one on
the Billboard article about that and I
couldn't believe this is a real article
and then yeah sure enough it yeah cuz
I'll write I mean what's it called
Royals was top of the hot what it's
called Hot 100 borås for like nine weeks
straight and then I think billboards
they take the YouTube views so like
calculate calculate that until like the
total like billboards score so they took
my views and like put it into like the
mix of okay so that so that's what
happened it was the fact that they were
counting the views because they they
tagged your song because they tagged
your video because it has the songs a
yeah the legit song it wasn't like a
cover and yeah right so and how did you
first know that Miley had seen it her
management company emailed me asking for
my address they wanted to send me a gift
so I'm just like alright yeah here's my
I use my address and then a week later I
got a bottle of champagne from and it
said from Eileen and my pimps from
Eileen my pimps really yeah so that
wasn't written out kind of a thing it
was more just yeah just a handwritten
thing for Miley and my pimps that was it
and then just a bottle of champagne okay
and my expensive champagne no it was I
looked into it it was just like a $20
bottle of champagne it was still cool
those the idea of getting champagne from
Miley yes right that's cool you're
asking if those genies like you
well I mean it this is the kind of thing
that you look into oh yeah I don't know
the first thing I did was like Google
like the kind of like champagne it was
yeah it was a hundred dollars right oh
my can buy from Walmart this is cheap
want cheap champagne yeah yeah she's got
that thing I'm stockpile I have it as a
trophy now I'm not gonna oh you didn't
crack it no no as a throw popped the top
no and then you eventually met her how
did that happen well that I went to that
same because a management or her manager
emailed me then I saw she was coming to
LA to perform an for concert so I'm like
I wonder if I emailed her manager if I
could if I could meet her so sure enough
I you know I typed out an email saying
hey like you know I'd love to see Miley
a concert on like a I go backstage and
meet her and then like the day of the
concert I got an email back saying hey
we got your backstage tickets to meet
Miley oh yeah so I'm like oh shoot we
got to go over there and then I met I
met her very briefly was more of like a
comeback stage meet-and-greet mm-hm and
I kind of went up to her we didn't talk
about the video but uh yeah we've got a
quick picture I pulled my shirt up in
the picture and she slapped my belly but
she knew who you were I yeah I think I
think so but you're not huh you're not
you're not 100% sure because she wasn't
like I love the videos you you just got
the opportunity when I met her I was
like hoping she would like bring it up
but I wasn't gonna be the one to bring
it up by the way I made the videos I was
waiting for her to like say something
because I felt like she was like you
know I thought she knew I was coming you
know right so then like yeah I just got
a quick picture like said hi and like
what on my way it was a really quick
meet-and-greet yeah but it was still
like thanks for the champagne I looked
it up $20 $20 saving it now you said
that it quickly went to you know sixty
million views or whatever now this is
the same video that you initially had to
take down right or did you not have to
take it down because there the
controversy over somebody saying that
were they they were in it my last video
was taken down was call me maybe on
chatroulette because some person didn't
want to be at it so I had to like take
it down then repost it but for wrecking
ball there was a false complaint where
like when you get like a copyright
complaint you like you get an email
saying hey so-and-so at from this time
this time like filed a complaint so then
once to it I'm like I have all the
written consent and permission like this
isn't this is a false complaint so then
like I went back and like you know told
YouTube and we got it all cleared up
so okay so cuz because when you go back
and look at some of the articles that
were being written at that time new
media rockstars and then there was a
your Facebook post that was about the
Maile video right that's about my
thought that you were gonna have to take
it yeah but it turns out you did yeah
because there was like I think three
reactions I usually like before like I
go on to the next person I usually say
hey like alright cool thing in the video
and like say yeah yes yes or no and
there's like I think two to three people
like that has such good reactions I
couldn't like ask him in time so then
next to me too quick so I thought for
sure that like it was a real complaint
coming in you know but it was it was a
fake complaint
so you're saying with the the call me
maybe video you kind of learned some
lessons about getting permission oh yeah
I mean how well cuz what happened with
that one did you have to take that one
down yeah I had to take it down and I
think it had yeah have like thirty
million views and had to take it down
and repost it without one person in it
who didn't want to be yeah I had a
brother face out and the person that
blurted out was actually a fan of the
videos but he was I think I believe is
he was underage hmm
so that was one of the main well so you
lost thirty million views on that call
me maybe video yeah and now and so then
with wrecking ball he said I'm gonna get
verbal permission mmm from every person
like video consent and everything yeah
so would you get permission it sounds
like you got it afterward or would you
start the chat and they'd be like hey I
got I got this thing and there's some
times where like as I would like be
dancing as I was going through and I
like catch your reaction right there
then I would ask them but sometimes like
a family recognize me but go hey are you
filming abut yeah do you want to be in
it and then like most of the times
they're singing that was like pretty
like we talked about it okay we're gonna
be singing this part but like some yeah
some of the reactions are just like they
just I asked him afterwards okay yeah I
mean I did you know cuz the way you
picture it is as a viewer is alright he
set up this whole elaborate thing and
then he just kept he just ran the
chatroulette and he just went through
the performance maybe you know maybe he
took all night and just went through the
performance yeah but I have I do like I
do certain part do the whole song all
the way through like I'll get like if I
give me good take a good reaction I'll
be all they are this this one's done and
I go to the next person I keep doing
that verse over and over again until I
get like I'll get what I need right cuz
it's got different stages like you've
got the part where okay well this part
I'm going to be with a sledgehammer
this part I'm gonna be on the wrecking
ball this part I'm gonna be on the
wrecking ball naked mm-hmm
but you could also cheat the reactions
in the edit if you wanted to say all
right I've got five great reactions due
to me being naked I'm gonna cheat one
reaction a little bit earlier yeah for
just me being on the ball for the first
time that's what we would do that's what
we yeah yeah they're all like the real
reactions yeah so every time I see a
reaction it is to the corresponding
video of you beside you didn't you
didn't to toy with that there's been a
few like to sync it up better I had a
like kind of toy with it but like they
were seeing like exactly what I was
doing in the videos you didn't you
didn't do any reality TV no no no what's
that okay then that actually as a viewer
makes me feel great you know because
that's what I assumed you were doing
yeah and so there's a there's it's a
purist approach which i think is pretty
cool
but it also means that it takes a lot
more time which one took the longest at
this point was it the my leman i would
say i think it was call me maybe took
the longest okay so how many different
sessions of recording we're talking
about for the mily winner for for the
one that took the longest for the Carly
a lot of like a lot of different really
there's been like during like different
days I'll take a week off and go back to
it like you know a week later or I take
days off and that got I don't like spend
like hours on it go away from it come
back to it so like how many nights do
you think you've committed to it it was
like over it was over definitely over a
month process of what's called the call
me maybe
same with wrecking ball like it was but
I think I'm definitely more experienced
now making these videos but the earlier
stages of me making these videos it took
me a lot longer because I was kind of
learning the ropes and how to like get
these reactions but yeah I'm a lot
better at it now so well I do think we
want to come back to you know I think
you're kind of in one sense kind of
answering a question that a lot of
people have for you that you've you've
also talked about because other people
have asked you in other interviews about
your video frequency you're kind of
getting at the heart of that at least
part of it which is how long it takes
you to create these videos yeah but
before we get to that and kind of come
back let's go full circle and go back to
little Steve a little Steve where you
from I'm from I was born and raised in
Macomb Michigan so uh why I move we
moved to Macomb Michigan but I have you
know beautiful mom beautiful
that too two sisters I'm the middle
child okay and yeah little Steve didn't
have a mustache or a beard and didn't
work bikinis I was I was really big into
around fourth grade I discovered my that
I liked music because like in third
grade I heard music like the first time
or like I was I thought music was a
passing phase growing up oh my god I
mean it's not gonna be around it's just
a passing phase
okay and then I don't mean like in the
world in the world I thought that's how
I knew music I'm like oh like people
always ask me at my favorite song I'm
like I don't like music it's just like
it's just here now it's just like you
know wow that's an interesting
perspective AK then and then I get it I
thought music is something that my older
stepsister is into but not me yeah
exactly then fourth grade came around
and my sisters like hey do you want this
some shady CD I'm like yeah I'll take it
and then ever since I became like a huge
Eminem fan and like I started dyeing my
hair blond from fourth to eighth grade I
had my hair bleached blonde really and I
wore baggy clothes and everything it was
I was really big and Eminem and I still
have all the words yeah I would actually
print off his lyrics and like read his
lyrics and like study his lyrics I was
like really dedicated fans or a student
of imminent I was would you learn I
learned a lot about his life you know I
learned you know that he came from
nothing and made a lot a lot of his life
and is very inspiring yeah
did your beautiful mom and beautiful dad
having concerns about the fourth-grade
obsession with Eminem they did they made
sure to have like whenever I had got
like an M&M CD it is always edited like
I'm like looking back like a Walmart
version the wall and it really bothered
me because it boy I bought one of those
one time that was a mistake
yeah it seems like a broken CD you can't
even what it is so yeah so when you
print it off the lyrics where they're
blanks in the lyrics oh no no no I was
seeing the lyrics I was learning all the
words yeah you can fill it in using
context clues to fill in curse words
yeah but in that but that satisfied
their concerns and so yeah emember work
like my sisters were always like talking
paracin and getting a dog we always want
a dog growing up my parents my dad
mainly my dad like oh you can't have any
nope no pets you need like a hamster or
something but no dogs and my sisters
were always like all about getting like
you know a dog but I all I wanted was a
parental advisory CD it's all what's one
of the most pairs like no you're not
yeah wait till you're older I'm like
alright so what's the first one that was
unedited diversity that actually bought
that was print Eliezer was like some
little Wayne CD I remember going through
a store I don't even know like what
little Wayne CD it was but like the
cover looked cool and I came out can I
get this CD because I saw a parental
advisory I saw a little wine I'm like
what is this they are fine you can you
can get it so yeah you wore her down
well no she advised him that's what it's
all about but I kept I kept breaking her
down then she finally she's like you
know yeah and then what did it feel like
to listen that do you remember felt like
a grown man I'm like this is what I was
missing out on like actually hear these
words now this is great it wasn't a
letdown he's like well I've been filling
in the blanks it's not really that
different no no it was definitely a very
rewarding to be able to like your
parental advisory CDs it was was that
lollipop song on that one Lil Wayne I
don't think though this was like a
earlier one okay yeah this is before
that we need a little little way a
little yeah before a little yeah still
had a foul mouth though I guess oh yeah
and so were you really the kind of kid
who was willing to kind of make a fool
of himself in front of class like I
think it was fourth grade were I it was
no it was before like the
bleached-blonde where i cracked a joke
and I think yeah I was third grade I
cracked a joke and then people were
laughing on the go wow I could be a
class clown and then I actually that was
pretty cool I call three were like you
know like school I I wasn't really that
like talkative out kind of kept to
myself had a small group of friends
it wasn't till like after I got out of
school where I kind of like you know did
the whole YouTube thing but you weren't
actively trying to be the center of
attention as a you know a middle
schooler I had my moments I'll have my
moments about trying to be funny but it
wasn't like always I try to be funny
there was those kids in school that
would always actively try to be funny
but I was more of just like I would like
kind of slide and say my thing and go on
my own way but right because you know
even like you uploaded your the Katy
Perry firework yeah
speech where you basically just read
that the lyrics and dramatic fashion
yeah and that was in college right yeah
and so when I saw that because it we
really relate to that like that was the
sort of the start of us developing an
audience was class was school was in
fact I remember the speech
that we had the opportunity to give in
middle school was the first time we like
commanded an audience right and so and
that was the first taste of like okay
you can develop something that makes a
group of people respond in a certain way
so I saw you did do that in college I
was like oh it's probably doing this all
along now I was very nervous for that
speech I don't know if yeah I know if
you can tell in that video but I
remember like we had like I figured like
this speech had to be about but remember
like I had that Dida like kind of like
you know say like the lyrics for the
speech right I remember going to the it
was a very crowded class of em being
very nervous and I got there only half
the class was there I was kind of like
bummed out yeah but I still even like
the class was like have fun I'm still
really nervous giving that speech it's
not in some ways that makes it more
awkward yeah and the class was very I
was hoping for a very lively and
energetic crowd but the whole class was
kind of like all right yeah yeah there's
that one pan to the does it feel like
the four people on that side of the room
yeah and they're like is this happening
now that you say you were nervous I
guess you could tell at the beginning
there's like there's the intro where
you're kind of saying let's try this is
what I'm gonna do
yeah and I don't know if you were like
trying to bait them that you didn't you
know because then once you go into the
lyrics and just like spoken word baby or
firework yeah it's that's where you
explore once I got into like you know
it's reciting like the lyrics that's
when I became alive yeah yeah brings me
back to when I was in a like my school
day I took I was in the theater arts
okay and uh sorry for stuttering I kind
of like talk a lot I talk very am I
talking too fast by the way no I mean
okay bring it on you're good I'm gonna
try not that we're southern so we talk
too slow but okay yeah make everyone
feel like they're talking to you I took
I started taking theater arts from like
ninth to twelfth grade and remember like
before like I would I do improv or like
go on stage I've always liked it really
nervous and the second I got on stage to
like do my lines I kind of that's when I
became alive I feel the same way towards
like YouTube videos where I get
extremely nervous and then like once I'm
actually doing it that's when I'm like
all right like I'm in this character
until till it's over
and so much of YouTube videos are their
performance oriented in kind of a
theater way so it it I can see that
resonating maybe from those high school
years of being involved in theater yeah
when you left high school what was the
what was the next
things well in like the ledger well you
have like in vector when I was taking
theater arts in 12th grade I started in
ninth grade and then when I went to high
school it was like from 10th to 12th
grade it was theatre arts like ninth
grade was a different school and when I
got from like the 10th to 12th grade
when you're in 12th grade your final
year of theater arts you can be a part
of the student news and Student News is
broadcasting from the entire school
where you can get all over that and
that's where I kind of like spawned into
like oh this is this is great because I
would make we would make like school
related videos weekly and they were
premiere like first hour of school
people everyone would see it so remember
like after like first hour we get out
everyone would be like oh like I saw
your you know I saw your video and stood
news it was great it was hilarious and
that kind of gave me inspiration to be
like oh this is this is something I can
do
were they sketches were they comedy it's
it started off as a movie quote where
like we would take a movie scene and
recreate it and it would be the very end
of student news there people will talk
about sports for school related topics
on the very end of Student News we would
be we would be movie quote people look
forward a movie quote uh-huh and then
like midway through we like senior year
we kind of got bored with it we're like
I wonder if we can like switch it up and
like do like comedy sketches so we asked
our teacher who can make comedy sketches
and sure enough we could and then we
just ended up making these sketches
based off like well for example one was
called serial killer where I was I was
force-fed waffles growing up as a boy
and fast-forward 10 years I'm now a
serial killer because I could never have
cereal growing up so I break into
people's houses take their cereal and I
kind of like just torture and kill their
cereal
yeah and that pretty much it played in
from the whole entire in first our whole
entire school and at the very end of the
video we said make sure to eat your
breakfast you know
before school because like a PSA yeah
yeah yeah which is important most
important meal of the day the whole
thing was just a random video nothing to
do with school then the very end we
decide make sure that your breakfast as
long as there's a moral you can do it
probably all these ketchup is how these
random random things on the very end we
kind of had like a school related thing
we could put in there but well you know
the thing that high school teachers and
administrators don't tell you is that
they want you to do these things because
they think it gives them a thrill man
yeah they want that kind of they want
that in their life too they don't that's
that's a secret for all your high
schoolers out there so you wanted to be
you wanted to be an actor not a youtuber
even I want that did
exist we're talking when you when did
you graduate from high school oh wait
mm Oh 8 so YouTube was very young but it
existed around your senior year in high
school acting came first playing
characters came first and I then I
realized after you know after I
graduated that can post he's old like
student news skits to YouTube and then
from there like my friend that I made
Student News with we all came together
like formidable group and we would make
sketches on YouTube okay and then yeah I
was more just like I wanted like just
play characters getting to acting and
there are those still around those oh
yeah they're still oh is that on your
channel um some of my favorite ones
around my side channel but if you do
some digging you can find some which is
this what's your side channel like Steve
carnal see parents even Cardinals
eternal - okay yeah so if you go back if
you sort by date to the beginning of
that I'm gonna I would see some some old
serial killer and another one called
prom those are on my second channel but
there's older ones there's like there's
a good handful of them that are just
kind of floating around lost on YouTube
known it even really knows about it
okay so you you kind of get a taste for
this acting thing you got a taste for
the comedy thing for making an audience
laughs and you graduate high school and
what happens I graduated I graduate high
school and then I I didn't I wasn't
really into the whole I didn't really
want to go I wanted to keep making
videos I wasn't really into going to
going to college and then my parents
talked me in like you did you know
YouTube's not paying your bills or
making videos and paying your bills you
should probably you know do the right
move and go to college so I ended up you
know going to like Community College and
I was goin [ __ ] Michigan Michigan
that's like I was going for like
communications I was aimlessly going I
didn't know what I was like I was just
kind of like going there to like figure
myself out and then yeah I just have I
think I don't know about like two years
and two years ago into college I
realized you know I should just focus
more on just making sketches and you
know do it full-time and so that was
like to 2010 probably you know two years
after graduating high school yeah 2010
outside so it seems like if you look at
your you look at your youtube history
that seems like the year that something
did click for you yeah yeah cuz if you
look back now on your Steve Cardinal
channel you got a parkour video at
800,000 views and then your second video
that I don't know what's private but
public videos it's fun on chatroulette
five minutes almost two million views
four years ago yeah
so was that just something you were
fooling around or were you thinking I'm
I'm gonna go big with this Cheryl that
was more of just it was a new sight and
I was more of it I was kind of fooling
around on it I didn't know I was gonna
take off it was more of like a side
thing and it took off I'm like I can
actually play characters on here and
have some fun with it and then
chatroulette took off of your video what
what what do you mean why are you just
saying this website is blowing up I need
to do something well yeah the chair will
let when the first can I forget when it
first came out but when it first came
out like everyone was going on there
yeah it was it was pretty big when I
first came out so that's when I could
decide to go there and like play a weird
character
yeah and that's where like the first
bikini video came through and it's not
actually on it's on a different channel
my whole my very first chatroulette
video was on a different channel it's on
it's like it's after my I was very big
in the I still am very big into playing
video games and my name was Dominator
0:05 on PlayStation and at the time I'm
like I made I was very big in the
PlayStation and I'm like you know what I
should make him like a youtube account
so I just took my you know my my
gamertag put it on YouTube and then I
mean it just blew up I'm like I don't
want to be have this big you know random
name on later 0:05 that I was dominated
or 0-5 at 7 8 9 when I first saw you
guys actually like walking by you guys
at 7 7 8 9 the first time you and I went
there going as like as Steve but like
people knew me as Dominator there's the
Dominator yeah so like it was 79 that
kind of like was like actually I needed
like cuz I thank it up to me so go
Dominator zero zero five I love your
videos and I'm just like my name is
Steve kind of like brought me down so
after a seven eight nine I kind of I
went full blown into Steve Cardinal and
I made that channel so well so you had
done the bikini a bikini clad
chatroulette video on the Dominator of
0:05 channel with viral yeah went viral
how high are we talking like millions
yeah it was I think like four that three
million views right now oh okay and it's
still up there yeah fine yeah yes it's
very hidden no I know it has hurt for
them and you were doing you didn't have
you didn't wear a bikini or lip sync and
all of your chatroulette videos and you
were trying other things
like you but you were all in to YouTube
Oh were you also in school I was all
I've always been big into YouTube I was
always I love watching YouTube I just I
watched it to this day every day of my
life I just I'm always on YouTube and
I'm just very fascinated by the whole
like everyone on YouTube there's so many
different like genres like this is blot
on YouTube you know when the fact that
you went to 7 8 9 and this is this is
long before like like I had like I think
50,000 describers during 79 all right
very very few people actually went 7 8 9
and that's a it's interesting I you know
I didn't realize that you were there and
that it was that he goes back that far
but you anybody who was at 7 8 9 was
already thinking I want to do this
this is this is there's you know where
I'm all in and we were definitely
thinking that it's yeah this was a time
because we actually like we drove from
is she from yeah Michigan in New York
and this was a time where like I didn't
really want to like do the whole College
thing I was trying like pursue YouTube
and try to figure it all out so this was
like 79 was like kinda like oh I was
opening my eyes to the whole YouTube
thing like I don't know is yeah it was
that way for a lot of people I mean a
lot of conversations on your biscuits
goes back to seven eight nine I still
have a visual of I was walking to the
Meetup and you guys are I think walking
you were walking away from and I was
walking towards it and I remember just
walking by you guys I'm just wow they're
a lot taller than I I'm a small guy so
like you guys are like that much taller
right we so did you have a lot of
traction as a gamer as well and are you
still doing that yeah I still I'm very
active in playing a game called Gears of
War on xbox 360 yeah but I don't
recorded a few sessions and I've been
meaning to kind of like record some of
it put like sorta on YouTube but I'm
more of just like I'm very competitive
competitive gamer and and you I try
recording and when I record I'd never
really talked as I'm playing I'm more of
like the cameras rolling like what do I
say what do I say but I love playing I
love playing video games that's like my
thing okay but but more as an outlet not
as not as a and entertainment source
yeah yeah not I can't be I can't do a PD
Pardo's That's not me
so if if we look at your Steve Cardinal
channel you can kind of see the
evolution of things you know there's
chatroulette videos and then other
videos that are like the
the public demonstration of absurdity
like just dancing in public or in a you
know the I chat of a Apple Store Apple
store it you know you really putting
yourself out there it was performance
art really
I think it all started from back in high
school there I'm very I'm very big into
cosplay dressing up in certain
characters and uh I think it was I was
11th grade where super smash bros melee
was coming out and all my friends
dresses like Mario Mario Luigi all the
characters and we just like running
around school and just like I got this
like rush like dressing up as he
characters and then after I graduated I
went my first time like going to like a
bigger B I could be on school I went to
familiar with warped or yeah I went to
warped or the day of a date like I went
to the the midnight screening of like
Dark Knight with Heath Ledger and I went
there addresses like a Joker makeup you
know the he thought his Joker makeup
yeah and then after you know like that
movie yet got out I'm like I was like
too wired to fall asleep I mean I was a
great movie I'm a big Batman fan and
then that same day of what like was like
the Warped Tour so I went to Warped Tour
in you know in the Joker makeup and just
like the energy I got from people were
just a joker like that's a great movie
and just like it felt so cool I felt
like I was actually I know it wasn't the
Joker but I'd be like I was like so in
it like I just came from the movie I was
just kind of like sporting like the
Joker Batman love and actually met Katy
Perry because of the Joker makeup
oh really yeah yeah we were kind of like
laying on the lawn like it's like warped
or it's like everyone's kind of like
walking around like waiting for the next
next band to play or whatever
remember Katy Perry was up in like 40
minutes okay we should like kind of like
lounge over here and I wafer - it's like
when she had I kissed a girl that was
like her big song about yeah yeah and I
remember we were laying out in like the
grass I was in my all my Joker makeup
and then I kind of I think yes Katy
Perry come and she's gonna back to the
backstage area I miss Katy Perry and she
actually she locked eyes with me and
approached me and Joker like Batman and
she came up to me like hey it's cool if
I get a picture and actually have a
picture of Katy Perry and Joker makeup
and then really yeah and that's what I
think what spawned me to like just dress
up in these words you know and you're
like I should I should probably put it
on YouTube and I should probably dance a
lot too because I'm not really I
whenever I meet people that always like
I thought you're gonna be more energetic
or more like dancing around but I'm like
no that's just like I get into these
characters and like like break free from
like my like you know not like I'm not
shop I'm not really you know I don't I
don't know it you bottle it up and kind
of release it kind of release like oh
yeah I release it on my videos so no I
get that I mean turn it on or turn it
off you have self control
yeah there's been a lot your person
exact there's been a lot of people that
many like wow you're a lot you're a
chill dude your children you know I
think what it is for me at least you
know I hate doing things that draw like
a public spectacle but if we decide that
we're going to do something once you
start doing it all you're thinking about
really is the audience that's gonna see
it on YouTube right you're seeing you're
thinking about not the person that's
being embarrassed but you're thinking
about the audience that's gonna watch
this and enjoy it yeah and when you have
that when you have that audience in mind
it really changes your your mindset yeah
I always like get a little nervous going
into those videos because I dress up you
know as a lady in some majority not a
majority but a good amount of my video a
lot a lot of my videos yeah now there's
a good finish now you can go that
thought you dress it like a lady yeah
what does you love it you want you wanna
know how it all started yeah okay so my
bikini day started when I had the whole
house I think the real reason you dress
up like women so much this is how the
whole bikini started me yeah my parents
my mom dad and sister like they were all
gone I lost myself I was looking my
parents basement at the time the great
start home alone some of my best moments
throughout my life so far my parents
basement I the whole basement myself had
an awesome room living it living to
genting role in living your parents
basement so all my whole family was gone
I'm like this wasn't Cheryl that was
first getting big so I'm just like I
have to loss myself I can like I can
like what can I do and then we had this
like storage area of the basement where
we had like all these like I thought
they were old bikinis like they were
like my old sister's old bikinis I
thought they were being like gonna go to
Goodwill or something I wasn't give them
away so I I'm going through the box and
there's a lot of bikinis in here so like
I can wear these for cheerleading like
play as a girl I'll chatter let him
dance around and ID
that's how I'll start I come like I had
a whole awesome myself put on the bikini
it's my sister's bikinis which sounds
really weird I know and you framed
yourself such that the guys who would
next to you would then see your backside
and your your back yeah I think you were
a woman yeah so yeah I did some of those
and that's when I did my first
chatroulette like song video it was to a
lady Gaga telephone and I just danced
around and trick people into thinking I
was yeah started off kind of like being
like showing a little bit of myself and
I would come in like oh you're dude yeah
those are great but yeah it all started
from being home alone and lots of things
happened but then I didn't when did your
parents first see it well what happened
was
that's right I danced around the bikini
I put the bikinis back in the box where
I got them from but I didn't know like
my sister was keeping those bikinis
because when the video after the video
went viral I wasn't expecting the video
get like millions of views so the video
got all its traffic and my sisters like
I just hear like a loud because I live
in the basement right I hear just like
loud scream like see what I heard that
was that for me that I hear like
stomping towards my do you like until my
direction like towards the basement it's
like the door busts open should we worry
about bikinis and it was like yeah and
she just like lost her mind on me and
I'm like she told my parents my parents
you weren't your sisters bikini living
what I was like yeah I ended up by
giving her money for new bikinis but I
didn't I thought they were all being
sent away I didn't know those were gonna
get her new bikinis yeah she's like huge
stuff was in there I'm soil them your
stuff was in your stuff wasn't in it's
weird if yeah yeah I get it I can see
where she's coming from but I thought
that was like being sent to right yeah
its finest Rangers that's a thrift store
yeah yeah ever since then I went and I
bought my own bikini put you a little
bit better
how did songs in real life start what
was the genesis well as I was going Amos
Lee going to college going for the
communications thing I was there just
one random class I forget what it was
called but in the class we had a lot of
free time like we worked in groups but
there would be certain groups of the
class where you kind of go off and do
your own thing we had a lot of free time
and I had this idea I mean my buddy had
this idea where we kind of like take
songs put them in like for those that
don't know what song is real life is
it's where you take like you take a
random song and mix it in with dialogue
to make songs more exciting so yeah so
uh pretty much I had this idea going
because I did going into class I'm like
hey do you guys want to be in this this
is the first songs were in life
uh-huh okay do you guys want to be in
this in this video though I guess so the
very first songs where I like the
classroom scene that's a day I met my
classmates yeah that's the first day
yeah
the firt the via the very first it
wasn't the first date class it's like
that like I never really talked to the
people like in that class okay show up
and oh yeah show up and leave and then
they're just like we have the whole
class to ourselves I'm like hey like
this is a perfect time to like film this
video had everything written out I'm
like all right guys cool with doing
these doing these lines and they're like
yeah and then you were like you you
what's your name you look like you could
be the instructor or at least you look
the most like lead instructor of all of
us here yeah it was not the destruction
yeah he wasn't I'm I do wanna be a
teacher is like yeah and then we're also
really close but we also like talking
everything and I've met them because of
songs in real life is the coolest thing
now so it's normal dialogue and you've
written this thing but then all of a
sudden it'll go into lip-synching a
little blurb out of nowhere which it
just it's one of those things that it's
a great idea but until you really see it
it doesn't totally click but then it's
like oh that's brilliant I should do 800
of these yeah
were you playing the music in the room
like on your phone for them to lip-sync
to well that there was um some way we
play the song beforehand to kind of like
get the idea of how how we're gonna be
in sync with it but there were times
where like the verse was too long we
couldn't get in sync properly so we
would have it playing in the background
we would I time it up and stop it
so yeah but for the most part we would
just like kind of say it without playing
the song
there's a few if you go back and watch
mainly the first one we're like what one
girls really off off sync with the song
but right well I got a question about
Malaysia really really should a lot of
your videos because there are two things
that they have in common I mean one
thing is a lot of them feature popular
music yeah you know copyrighted music
and the other is a lot of feature a lot
of people you know now that you're
trying to work in and get permission on
that kind of thing but specifically with
the and those are both sort of really
dangerous areas when you're making
videos right could come back to bite you
but specifically with the copyrighted
music how does that work in terms of and
the guy trying to make a living on
YouTube you're you know
bored is picking that up and basically
crediting Miley for that she's getting
some money I guess for those plays do
you get a portion of the I mean how does
it work in terms of monetizing those
videos for songs my life for for
anything that features music that's
either been tagged or whatever for like
majority of my videos onto the supernal
channel I'm not like making any money
from it recent like as of recently I'm
like when I do these new like songs
during life videos I try it like I'm
doing I'm working on new songs we left
right now and I try getting all the
songs cleared but like a lot of the song
companies are really strict or like they
charged to one of this I'm not gonna say
what song it was but one of the songs
they wanted to charge like I think five
it was like five or eight thousand for
every five million views the video gets
I'm like I can't afford to pay this
company like for the rest of my life
yeah video doing well but like for all
those videos I'm not like making money
from any of those videos even
wreckingball I didn't make a dime from
it okay so that money just goes right
back to to my league yeah okay people
know share I got nothing from a from a
wrecking ball unfortunately but uh yeah
I got my start like making money from
like before I started making videos like
higher quality videos I would enter
video contests I would go to Google type
in like online video contests that's
where I got like I think I saved up
about like twelve thousand dollars and
that's where I got like my big start and
the like doing what doing what I'm doing
now so but if you're not making money
off of the most popular video you've
ever made it like where are you making
money it kind of reflects on my other
video is in like a lot of the money I
made came from like things off of
youtube like recently I did a thing with
Captain Crunch and that was like you
know like things I do like off of like
off of my channel that's where I kind of
like what was that like as an example
Captain Crunch yeah it was uh I was
animated with Captain Crunch on their
channel and we just talked in the cereal
bowl on the YouTube Captain Crunch
channel and the cool thing is that
growing up it's all my favorite cereal
so like being able to work with him was
just like insane like and awesome want
spawn from wrecking balls even at
captain I met the captain that it all
spawned from wrecking ball I saw Becky
mullet okay we want to interview honor
the Captain Crunch talk show it's all
gonna be animated we're gonna animate
you I'm just like this is amazing I love
Captain Crunch well you know the
interesting thing is one of the most
recent videos on your Stephen Cardinal
channel is that when we started watching
you know someone starts with Jay Leno
it's like your feature video right yeah
that was for the Lady Gaga video the
first chatroulette video
right and the second thing is you like
you show a picture of something kind of
a you know just a video that like a
static shot and you hear a phone call
from a commercial casting age yeah that
you've reported that the voicemail yeah
that was that when we talked about that
that was not for our audition right so
tell because you're talking about these
other opportunities and when I first
heard that I was like is this gonna be
some like artsy video where he's trying
to make a point about how he's bigger
he's more than just the guy from that
video but as I as an unfolded I was like
no this is he's that's just kind of his
calling card it's almost like you're
trying to convince the audience that
like hey I did this I should be able to
do XY and Z is that is that what's going
on that's what that's what I was going
for that video just yeah right that's it
you nailed it on the money okay and so
you were you were about to talk about
that particular audition oh yeah that
was okay so um yeah I got an audition
after a wrecking ball like went viral I
got an audition to try out for a hey
Willy Wonka commercial and I'm like oh
this is this is awesome I of course I
want to try all so I get there and like
well before I got there I got like we
time I got a script for the commercial
and I mastered I would have rehearsed
apart in the mirror every day I was just
like I'm gonna nail this audition and
then I get to get to the audition and uh
I check in and I go what did you get the
new the new script change and I'm just
like there's script change no I didn't
get it and then they gave me the script
and all my lines are completely
different oh gosh so and I have about
like five minutes before going into the
audition so I'm kinda like reading it
over reading it over and then I remember
the girl was auditioning was like hey
I'm so-and-so like I'm auditioning with
you like how did you get this call then
I'm like oh the people making the
commercial saw my wrecking ball video
and they wanted me to come audition and
she's like oh like my agent like she was
like very surprised that that was even a
thing yeah I was surprised too you know
but then I remember going into the
audition I was expecting that maybe like
you know a few people there's like 20
people in there and there's like they're
all on one side on the other side there
was like you know the stage of the
lights and everything and it had like a
monitor of the script thankfully and
then like the whole audition I was just
reading off off the script it was like I
totally bombed the audition I'm like
this is a really it was my first like
major like big audition but I remember I
mean it was like it was a rough time for
me to that audition but it was it still
very memorable and I it's fun looking
back at it does it inform your
or your strategy in terms of what you
want to do as far as be and I mean to
still be an actor I mean what's the
split between YouTube and pursuing act
well with YouTube like where I'm going
with it now it's just like I've been
working on all these videos to where
like I'm playing these characters that
like I don't have to audition for I can
just be like you know what I can put on
this costume and just be this character
so where I'm at now is just I'm working
on these all these videos to where like
I don't have to you have to audition you
know so I'm just like so focused on what
I'm doing now and but like I'd all
started from acting you know but I can I
think I can say I'm acting on YouTube
you know like I'm just playing these
sure yeah I I'm in in like a traditional
medium if you wanted to get into that
because I you know the producer side of
me certainly sees it okay
you have an innate sense of your look
and what you can do to make things more
ironic so a guy with your look and a
dress lip-syncing to Katy Perry or the
things that you do it's like okay
that guy should be in every Super Bowl
commercial that guy should be and he
should be the comedic spot in this next
movie opposite Bradley Cooper you know
that type the wheels start turning in
that way yeah and I assume that because
of wrecking ball and everything else
that there's a lot of people coming out
of the woodwork to get you involved in
that type of stuff if you wanted to
mm-hmm well there hasn't been like any
things that really caught my interest
like the thing that caught my interest
most was Captain Crunch in Willy Wonka
but I haven't really I've gotten like
certain things to do like independent
movies or like but with independent
movies you got to like look into the
director and if you're not a fan of the
director then you can't really mm-hmm
you're not to be able to work with that
person but like yeah I've I don't know
I've gotten like a lot of opportunities
but nothing really like hit me like were
like where I want I don't know but your
main strategy is is YouTube yeah yeah
YouTube UTI YouTube right now it's what
I'm that's what I'm going for but
whatever comes my way if I could if I
can go to audition and audition for this
really cool part in a movie that I'm
gonna go for you're gonna it's you're
gonna take those opportunity I'm gonna
take the opportunities yeah I definitely
cuz yeah just playing characters and I'm
a big movie guy go to movies like once
or twice a week well I think I think
somebody as someone who just who's a
who looks at you know your channel looks
at your history on YouTube the fan says
you did this
Miley video and now I've got to wait a
year for the next one or you did songs
in real life and I've got to wait
however many many months and I really
and I really feel like you sense this
you know when you look at your your
Twitter you like in October you tweet
something like I go away so I can come
back ten times better get ready to get
sick of me I'm staying around for a
while this time like you know that
people's perception of oh yeah is that
you don't have a regular schedule yeah
and it seems like you you sense that and
there's a sort of a sense of pressure or
even and then there'll be a vlog six
months ago you vlog I've got a 80s theme
song in real life coming up I got a 70s
theme song or a life coming out and then
it's the and in the comments below er
you'll not hear crickets you know well I
I made sure that they didn't have to
give a confirm release they cuz I'm very
bad at that well I like a lot of my
video ideas I just did Little Mermaid in
real life and that idea has been
sticking with me for like two years and
like I never actually went through with
doing it until like you know just like a
couple months ago yeah but like a lot of
my videos ideas they stick with me for a
long time like sometimes a month
sometimes even years and like I feel
like I like grow my content if it stays
with me like to the point of like over a
year or two then I know it's a good idea
but I have that idea so we're like like
after like a month or two like that idea
kind of dissolves oh my god you know
what that wasn't the best idea but like
I have I do have a very inconsistent
uploading schedule and I feel like every
time I upload a video I'm always like I
wonder if it's gonna do well I'm always
very like on edge of its gonna do well
like every time I post a video I'm I
like I'm very like I'm very underwear
how it's gonna do so you're you're so
trigger shy that you're not shooting
things is what you're really telling me
when you get when you get a hundred
million views on a video and then 130
million 31 million views on a video and
then you you a few months later you did
then you did the Mariah Carey Christmas
one and then it's a year over a year
later and you haven't done another one
yeah
that sounds crazy to me right is it is
this a problem
say the problem is just like my choice
of of I don't know it's how I work it's
how I that's how I operate it's very
because I a lot of youtuber that'll be
youtubers they stay consistent like
they're on a consistent schedule and
I've tried to like getting that that
formula of always posting but I always
it's just not for me I feel like I'm
forcing myself and they're like trying
to put up videos are you afraid is that
what you really said a second ago Steve
did you say how-how'd I say what I said
you said that you're afraid that it then
it might not be great so like when I'm
when I go into like posting a video I'm
out I always think cuz people always say
oh the videos playing it like I'll do
well but like for a Little Mermaid I
like a lot of my videos that go into it
thinking I wonder like who still sick
cow eyes post like I take a lot of time
off I'm gonna come back and I always
wonder who's like still sticking around
whom the video goes viral you like a
wave of all these new subscribers yeah
then if you don't post right away that
they become inactive subscribers to
where like they're not gonna be like you
know actively following you
yeah so when I go into posting a new
video I don't know how many people out
of my like you know four or five lines
with robbers are gonna come back you're
gonna come back yeah but wait okay you
take a lot of time off is it so it maybe
it's not fear maybe it's that you're
just doing something else
what are you doing your time off well I
I spent a good amount of time working on
a animated video called do you want to
build a meth lab it was like a parody of
do you want like do you wanna build a
snowman I kind of was like the co-writer
on that it did very well on like a
channel called an amine mhm and I do
like a lot of side things that were like
yeah I do a lot of writing into a lot of
this stuff I've been working on now is
like stuff I've been building up yeah so
you're staying busy I'm saying I'm
saying very active very busy and like
behind closed doors I'm still like very
I'm running all the comments and I just
want to get in there and be like hey
like I want to show people what I'm
working on but that like you should how
that works out like for 70s and 80s and
my vlogs like I talk about things then
like they don't come out for like months
or years people like where are they
where are they
but I make sure not promise on your
release days cuz I'm very bad with
release dates I'm very bad with that so
the 70s and 80s songs in real life are
still gonna oh oh they're happening and
they're gonna be good they're gonna be
very good I will say for 80 songs in
real life they're all 80 songs of course
I play overweight Marty McFly I have I'm
gonna have like a fat jumpsuit and
everything gonna have the DeLorean like
I'm very I'm committed to making because
like the songs were live one through
for they're very kind of like they have
a very cheesy homemade feel to him and
for 70s 80s I'm trying to go for like a
more like professional production like
have it done in a different light you
know how are you achieving that is that
is that you know taking advantage of
friends where I'm located I'm having
like friends like better equipment
everything like better lighting because
like some of my videos like all songs
were like one through four like I don't
have like proper lighting and like it's
not film the best you know kind of like
kind of pull the camera out and just
film like oh I read that like here's his
line like let's let's film this but like
what I'm doing now is kind of like just
putting a lot more thought into it like
taking more time away to like make sure
I want to post what I'm posting yeah I
don't want to like get an idea then like
that week like posted cuz I feel like if
I do that I might not be the biggest fan
I don't know I like being active for
small amounts of time and I kind of like
taking a step back where people get sick
of me I get sick of myself then I kind
of come back and like I don't know cuz
yeah like I said before to be like you
know successful on YouTube you got to be
actively like you gotta be like
consistent you know but I'm not really I
can't do it you know I gotta like go
away to come back all the time it's very
yeah it's it's hard to explain but I
just I love how it's doing and then what
I learned from all this is that like
when everybody goes viral I have this
whole like wave coming through but then
like people actually want to stick
around will stick around and people that
like that leave because you're inactive
they shouldn't be there anyway I want
people like actually gonna like stick
around so what I've learned from being
inactive is that the true viewers do
stick around which is really cool I've
never really understood why people have
a desire to unsubscribe to a channel
that's not active yeah that doesn't make
any sense
yeah I'm subscribing to a channel that's
very active that you don't like that's
different
well yeah I've gotten like I think it's
just a threat to get more content yeah
yeah there's been comment saying if you
don't post videos I'm gonna subscribe
and I just see those online please
unsubscribe I don't want you to like be
subscribed for a consistent material
that's not that's not who I am is that
what I'm doing so what's the release
date on the next video we gave you the
opportunity to it's funny because we you
know I I'm trying to feel the facial
expression that I'm directing at you and
I think that it's like I don't know what
you're talking about like do it because
we are so I'm trying to learn from your
perspective right
now because rhett and I are so okay this
is going well we got a double down you
got to keep it coming you got to keep
giving it to him because they think we
can't they might not come back but the
place we do relate though it's
interesting because there's a little bit
of a split personality and our YouTube
lives because we have our what we can
still call our main channel which hasn't
had a video yeah six months six months
yeah and you know I will say we do have
those in the pipeline and I there is a
release day but I'm not gonna give it
because maybe we won't miss it but I
think I can relate to that too but when
you have daily videos when you do five
or six videos a week and they're doing
so well it's like okay then that's a
comfort take the time off the main
channel so it's not really a fair
comparison right we took a week break or
a two week break for the holidays for
good mythical morning we were you know
it I was very anxious especially a year
ago when we did it because are they
going to come back and yeah everyone
came back two weeks later and a little
bit more came back because we took it
away for a little bit and it actually
was a good thing but the way that
entertainment is built the way that the
Machine of entertainment is not a
youtube thing is that you're you're only
as funky as your last cut so to speak
you know yeah yeah you you gotta keep
giving them something or they're gonna
forget about you and then you know but
you've you seem to have totally come to
grips with this is who I am this is this
is my approach I'm going away I want to
go and then I will come back oh I'll
come back baby I'm coming back and
you've already proven that I mean when
you look at even before wrecking ball
you went away yeah and you had a big one
and the coolest thing about coming back
is all your all your life answers oh
he's back he's coming back and you're
like seeing those like the cow monsters
like very inspiring I'm I love it is
there a new thing in your mind that
you're gonna bring I know there's
another chatroulette yeah and that
there's more songs in real life but do
you have another thing that could be
your next big thing there's a big dance
number a big dance number is gonna be
coming I'm not gonna give any release
dates on that but
it's inspired from the video it's called
Keyser hideaway the song is called
hideaway bike by kaiser and it's all
filmed in one take and i'm kind of doing
like something like that all shot on one
take like a big dance number where i'm
gonna be dressed as certain characters
cosplaying and skim it's gonna be fun so
that's one idea right there and yeah
there's been a few things that kind of
like venturing because i didn't i never
want to be known for like just dressing
up in a bikini or like you know dressing
up as women i wanna kind of get away
from that and like try new things and
have different like categories on my
channel you know mm-hmm but yeah I'm
definitely trying new things and it's
gonna be to me interesting it's gonna be
fun alright well we'll stick around
alright what we wait we will not
unsubscribe alright thank you I do
appreciate no threats sign the table man
thanks for making his ear biscuit it's
already over
alright that's it that's all it takes
alright and there you have it our ear
biscuit with Steve Cardinal tweet at
Steve let him know what you thought of
this use hashtag ear biscuits his
Twitter handle is Steve ste ve Cardinal
spelled a little different than you
might think
kar Dyn al you also also appreciate you
leaving a review on iTunes and you can
comment along in the conversation on
soundcloud you know I am I've noticed a
pattern that has been established here
when we talked to people but really this
has been multiple people that we talked
to that either you know we want them to
make more videos or we want them to do
this we want them to do that and we
start trying to convince them to do
those things while they're here with us
like it's some sort of motivational
interaction well I you know I think yeah
I mean I acknowledge this the
incredulous look on my face when he
talked about you know how he just him
deciding not to put out content or to to
wait or to get things right because we
just want to you know we get things out
there I mean we talked about our reasons
but yeah the reason why we want to push
them is I want to see more content from
the guy it's a selfish motivation and
we're also producers we've talked about
that before too I
I think there's an interesting third
thing and we've learned to let go of
certain things okay you know hire an
editor hire a producer hire qualified
people to help us create more content
and I you know this is a conversation
way back at VidCon there's people I I
don't know if this is Steve but there
are a lot of youtubers who are hesitant
to turn the corner of relinquishing any
level of control on their content and it
holds them back I think because we were
refreshed and having let go of some of
that you know it's oh we can oh this has
actually worked I don't have to do
everything I can give notes and we can
get more stuff done there's a lot of
people who because we're all self-made
that there's just a resistance to
letting go of any aspect of yeah well
yeah and I just I don't you know people
already have this feeling that okay I'm
gonna go on air biscuits and I might end
up crying and I don't know if anybody
has actually cried yet okay people have
been maybe gotten close but I'm gonna
talk about something personal or
whatever but now they're gonna add to
that I'm gonna Rhett link you're gonna
try to get me to do more of whatever I'm
doing I mean yeah we need maybe we don't
need to come on so maybe maybe we should
maybe that's what this is about and I
just you know for me I was just you know
I was wondering with Steve is it is it a
personnel issue no he doesn't have
people working for him but or is it a
motivation issue or I think the thing he
was able to describe what it was it's a
choice
it's an artistic choice on his part and
it's neither of those things and what he
is doing takes more time than you might
think
yeah that was cool to find out see
that's what happens when you get a
biscuit is that yeah we we might apply
some pressure but we learned some things
hey have you learned something today let
us know hashtag ear biscuits we have
learned that we will be back again next
week that really didn't make any sense
but you know cuz we kind of knew that
all along right you have you just
learned it that we will be back next
week even though you probably already
thought that that was the case so maybe
if this is the first time you've ever
listened to an ear best
and you don't know what you're listening
to well thanks for listening we will be
back next week our names are rhett and
Link we make this podcast it's called
deer biscuits they're learning a lot
right here at the end
[Music]
[Music]